This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Some years ago, a homeless woman was being discharged at a Philadelphia hospital. On her way out, nurses noticed the woman was wearing flip-flops. It was January, and Januaries in Philadelphia can get very cold. Nursing director Julie Munger had an idea. Her daughter was a basketball player and had left a bunch of old sneakers in the trunk of Julie's car. Would one of those pairs fit the homeless woman? They went out and took a look, but the shoes were all a size and a half too small for the woman's feet.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几年前，费城一家医院正在为一名无家可归的女性办理出院手续。在离开时，护士们发现这位女士穿着人字拖。当时正值一月，费城的一月可能会非常寒冷。护理主任朱莉·芒格想到了一个主意。她的女儿是一名篮球运动员，在朱莉的汽车后备箱里留下一堆旧运动鞋。其中有一双会适合这位无家可归的女士吗？她们走出去看了一眼，但鞋子对这位女士的脚来说都小了一个半码。
That's when Julie told a reporter from WTXF TV, things took an unexpected turn. So as I was leaving she's like your shoes are nice. I said well what size are your feet and she's like a 10. Julie looked down at her own shoes. They were a size 10. They were also super comfortable and she loved them. Like these are a 10 do you want these and she just cried and thought these are 10, do you want these? And she just cried and thought it would be great. So I just gave her the shoes.
正如朱莉对WTXF电视台记者所说的那样，事情从那时起发生了意想不到的转折。当时我正要离开，她说你的鞋子真好看。我说，你的脚穿多大码？她说10码。朱莉低头看了看自己的鞋。那是10码的。而且穿起来超级舒服，她很喜欢。就像“这些是10码的，你想要吗？”她当时就哭了，心想“这些是10码的，你想要吗？”她当时就哭了，觉得这太棒了。所以我就把鞋子给她了。
Julie unlaced her shoes and handed them to the other woman. Perhaps you've had experiences like this yourself. Our sister show, My Unsung Hero, often features stories like this where people reach out to help one another in unusual acts of generosity. But the reason these stories stand out is because they're at odds with the way most of us feel treated as we go about our days.
朱莉解开鞋带，把鞋递给了另一位女士。也许你自也有过这样的经历。我们的姊妹节目《我无名无姓的英雄》经常播出这样的故事，讲述人们如何在慷慨的非常之举中向彼此伸出援手。但这些故事之所以引人注目，是因为它们与我们大多数人在日常生活中感到被对待的方式格格不入。
We don't feel seen and heard. We feel ignored and passed over. This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we examine the reasons behind the growing disconnection in our schools, hospitals and workplaces and what we can do about it. It's also the start of a series that has long been a favorite with listeners, Relationships 2.0. In the coming weeks, we will look at the art of negotiation and ways in which we can get along better with the people in our lives.
我们感觉不到自己被看见、被倾听。我们感觉自己被忽视、被冷落。本周的《隐藏的大脑》以及《隐藏的大脑Plus》上的配套故事中，我们将探讨学校、医院和职场中日益疏离背后的原因，以及我们能做些什么。这也是一个长期以来深受听众喜爱的系列节目“人际关系2.0”的开篇。在接下来的几周里，我们将探讨谈判的艺术，以及如何与我们生活中的人更好地相处。
When boarding a train or subway, or going shopping at the mall, we may take in hundreds of people at a glance. On a Zoom call for work, the faces of our co-workers fit into a grid. Even when we are spending time with close friends and family, our familiarity can get in the way of really seeing the person in front of us. Alison Pugh is a sociologist at Johns Hopkins University. She studies how we relate to one another and how this has changed over time.
当登上火车或地铁，或者去商场购物时，我们可能一眼就能看到数百人。在工作的Zoom会议上，同事们的面孔挤在一个网格里。甚至当我们与密友和家人共度时光时，我们的熟悉感也会妨碍我们真正看清眼前的这个人。艾莉森·皮尤是约翰斯·霍普金斯大学的社会学家。她研究我们如何与彼此建立联系，以及这种联系随时间发生了怎样的变化。
Alison Pugh, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Alison, growing up, you were the youngest of five children. You have a story about the first new bathing suit you ever owned. Can you tell me that story? Sure. You know, right, the youngest of five,
艾莉森·皮尤，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。艾莉森，在你成长过程中，你是家里五个孩子中最小的。你有一个关于你拥有的第一件新泳衣的故事。能跟我讲讲那个故事吗？当然。你知道的，作为五个孩子中老幺，
it was a generally loving environment. But I would say it was one my mother still sometimes calls it benign neglect. So I did not get a bathing suit that wasn't owned by someone else until I was in college. And I went myself to a department store and picked out I think a pink bathing suit that I wanted instead of the you know scores of other kinds I had had over the years. The bathing suit story is one of many incidents where Allison remembers she was seen as one kid in a crowd.
那是一个总体上充满爱的环境。但我会说，那是一种我母亲有时仍称之为“良性忽视”的环境。所以直到上大学，我才穿上一件不是别人穿过的泳衣。我自己去百货公司挑选了一件我想要的粉红色泳衣，而不是那些年我穿过的无数种其他泳衣。这件泳衣的故事是艾莉森记得自己被视为人群中普通一员的众多事件之一。
It wasn't about being treated badly. It was about being ignored. Another time, Allison remembers coming home in middle school upset because some boys in her school were bothering her. She told her mother what had happened. I remember coming home kind of full of outrage and being like, this is not okay. You know, they shouldn't be doing this. And I was trying to figuring out, I just did not handle it. And she did not take it seriously at all, you know, unfortunately. She just kind of said, oh, that's because they like you.
这并不是说受到了糟糕的对待。而是关于被忽视。另一次，艾莉森记得自己在中学时闷闷不乐地回到家，因为学校里的一些男孩在捉弄她。她把发生的事情告诉了母亲。我记得回家时满腔怒火，觉得“这太不对劲了”。你知道的，他们不该这么做。我当时在想办法，只是自己没处理好。而她完全没有把这当回事，你知道的，很不凑巧。她只是说，“哦，那是因为他们喜欢你。”
That was her rationale. And at the time, I remember a really sharp disjuncture between my own, I would say, half-desperate outrage and her kind of semi-humorous, oh, you know, they just like you. So you felt that you weren't really seen by your mom? No, that was a big moment of a kind of cognitive dissonance between what I thought was going on and her response for sure.
那是她的理由。当时，我记得我内心那种近乎绝望的愤怒与她那种半开玩笑的“哦，你知道的，他们只是喜欢你”之间存在着非常尖锐的脱节。所以你觉得你妈妈并没有真正看懂你？不，那是一个强烈的认知失调时刻，介于我以为正在发生的事情和她的反应之间，绝对是这样的。
I did not feel seen. Allison is now a mom of three daughters herself. She remembers one incident when the shoe was on the other foot. At the time we were living in California and there would be old boxes or, you know, interesting rocks or, you know, kind of things that they'd be on the sidewalk, obviously, either somebody – part of nature that was just there or some things that other people were putting out for either garbage or for people to pick up. And my daughter was always the one to pick them up.
我感觉自己没有被看见。艾莉森现在自己也是三个女儿的妈妈了。她记得有一次情况反过来了。当时我们住在加利福尼亚州，人行道上经常会有旧盒子，或者你知道的，有趣的石头，或者你知道的，诸如此类的东西，显然，要么是属于大自然的一部分，就那么在那儿，要么是其他人放出来当垃圾或是供人捡拾的东西。而我的女儿总是那个去捡它们的人。
So she had a name for them. She called them her inventions. She was very young. I think she meant that they were a kind of art or maybe that she was inventing, that she would be imagining what she could do with them or something, but I really viewed them as junk. I actually threw them out and she still remembers that and reminds me. And, you know, to me it's really a primary moment of me not seeing her and how she viewed these small, we'll call them treasures. Allison started to notice these moments of unseeing or misseeing as she went about her
所以她给它们起了一个名字。她把它们叫做她的发明。她当时很小。我想她的意思是它们是一种艺术，或者也许她认为这是发明，她会想象她能用它们做些什么之类的，但我真的把它们当成垃圾。我其实把它们扔了，她至今还记得并提醒我。而且，你知道的，对我和她来说，这确实是一个主要的时刻，反映出我没有看见她，也没有看懂她是如何看待这些小小的、我们称之为宝物的东西的。艾莉森开始在她的一天中注意到这些视而不见或看错的时刻。
days. One time, during a visit to a new doctor, her physician did a quick evaluation, saw some elevated numbers, and advised Allison to eat fewer cookies. Now, Allison happens to love cookies, but she also wanted to tell the doctor, shouldn't you learn more about me and my lifestyle before leaping to a conclusion?
有一次，在拜访一位新医生时，她的内科医生做了快速评估，看到一些数值偏高，并建议艾莉森少吃饼干。现在，艾莉森恰好很喜欢饼干，但她也想告诉医生，在仓促得出结论之前，难道你不应该更多地了解我和我的生活方式吗？
It didn't land well at all. You know, I just, I have a very unusual lifestyle, I think, that she probably doesn't see very often because I row crew and I have done so for 30 years. And right now I'm involved in a team that's very intense in Washington, DC, which involves, you know, one to two hours daily. I also don't have any caffeine, I don't have any alcohol. You know, there's just, I think I'm an unusual person health-wise, and so when she was like, you know,
这根本没有起到好效果。你知道的，我只是，我认为我有一种很不寻常的生活方式，她可能不常看到，因为我练习赛艇，而且我已经坚持了30年。现在我正参与华盛顿特区一个非常高强度的团队，这需要，你知道的，每天一到两个小时。我也不摄入咖啡因，不饮酒。你知道的，我觉得自己在健康方面是一个很不寻常的人，所以当她说，你知道的，
these are elevated, try not to have so many cookies, she didn't see the person she was talking to. She didn't really have all that context that can produce a good witnessing moment, and along with it, good advice. And I think many people have these experiences, right? You go to the doctor and, you know, even if the doctor is very competent, you know, he or she spends, you know, all their time staring at a computer screen and asking you questions and glancing at you once every 15 seconds. I think many of us have had experiences like that. And you have the sense, is my doctor actually
这些指标偏高，尽量少吃点饼干时，她并没有看清她正在与之对话的人。她其实并没有掌握所有那些能够产生好的见证时刻以及随之而来的好建议的背景信息。我想很多人都有过这样的经历，对吧？你去看医生，而且，你知道的，即使这位医生非常称职，你知道的，他或她也把所有的时间都花在盯着电脑屏幕上，问你问题，每15秒才瞥你一眼。我想我们很多人都有过这样的经历。而你会有一种感觉，我的医生真的在
listening to me or watching me or seeing me or not? Yeah, the fabulous writer Abraham Verghese has called that the eye patient, that we're all to some degree an eye patient, meaning a patient that exists almost more by computer than in our holistic embodied selves in front of each other. And that, if that is how you feel, that often will affect whether or not you do what they say. Like, it's going to take a lot more than that to have me stop eating cookies. So as a sociologist, Alison, you've conducted some of your research by carrying out dozens of in-depth interviews. A few years ago you interviewed a chaplain whom you call Hank. It was a very intense conversation but at the end
听我说话、看我、看到我，还是没有？是的，伟大的作家亚伯拉罕·弗吉斯将此称为“电子病人”，意思是我们在某种程度上都是电子病人，这意味着这样一个患者，与其说是坐在彼此面前具有整体血肉之躯的活生生的人，倒不如说更多地是通过电脑存在的。而且，如果这就是你的感受，那通常会影响你是否会听从他们的话去做。就像，要让我停止吃饼干，需要的可不止这些。所以作为一名社会学家，艾莉森，你的一些研究是通过进行几十次深入访谈来开展的。几年前你采访了一位你称之为汉克的院牧。那是一次非常激烈的对话，但在对话结束时，
of it he had something to tell you about what the exchange meant to him. Tell me that story. Sure. Yeah, Hank, he started off as a programs for low-income youth in the community. So he started tutoring centers and I think sports camps and all sorts of things to try and reach kids. And by his account, he did reach them. They would come to his tutoring centers and they would kind of hang out with him and share stories. And he felt like he had attained some real connection to those youth. And he was so proud of it, as he's telling me. And then he gets a job in another city, moves there, but he ends up losing that job and feeling really defeated in that moment.
他有些话要对你讲，关于这次交流对他的意义。把那个故事讲给我听听吧。当然。是的，汉克，他最初是社区中面向低收入青年的项目的负责人。所以他创办了辅导中心，我想还有体育营地以及各种各样的东西，试图去接触孩子们。据他所说，他确实接触到了他们。他们会来到他的辅导中心，跟他在那里闲逛并分享故事。他觉得他与那些年轻人建立了一些真正的联系。而且当他跟我讲述时，他是多么地引以为傲。然后他在另一个城市找到了一份工作，搬到了那里，但最终他失去了那份工作，在那个时刻感到非常受挫。
And so he leaves that and he comes to be a chaplain in the hospital in which I was doing some observations. And so he talks to me about this trajectory. And at the very end of the exchange, he talked to me about what it was like to be interviewed. And he said, you know, this was very powerful. And then he said, And this is not true just of Hank, right? You've heard this from other people as well? Oh, yeah. It's something that's very common. People often say, oh, this was just like therapy. It's not like therapy because I'm not really there to solve any problems or really to counsel them in any way. And they know that. So it's more like it's the language we have for that feeling of being seen.
所以他离开了那里，来到我正在进行观察的一家医院担任院牧。于是他跟我谈到了这段经历。在交流的最后，他跟我谈到了被采访是怎样的体验。他说，你知道的，这非常有力量。然后他说，而且这不仅适用于汉克，对吧？你从其他人那里也听到过这种说法？哦，是的。这是非常普遍的现象。人们经常说，哦，这感觉就像做治疗一样。这并不像治疗，因为我并不是真的去解决任何问题，或者以任何方式真正去辅导他们。他们知道这一点。所以这更像是我们用来形容那种被看见的感觉的语言。
Music Allison started to see that the act of really noticing another person, paying attention to them, being present for them, this was not just something that was nice to have. It was something that people craved. She heard from one doctor who told her that her patients often seem to need this kind of attention when she first started her practice how much she was supposed to be attending to the mothers rather than the children. That was something that was a surprise to her. She often found herself giving,
音乐 艾莉森开始明白，真正注意到另一个人、关注他们、为他们陪伴在侧的行为，不仅仅是一件锦上添花的事情。这是人们梦寐以求的事情。她从一位医生那里听说，当她刚开始行医时，她的病人们似乎经常需要这种关注——即她应该更多地关注母亲们，而不是孩子。这让她感到意外。她经常发现自己在提供，
say, parenting advice or talking about car seats or talking about what it's like when you can't get any sleep or something like that. And the mother's desperately needed that. She felt their need on the other end, but she often felt like she told me she didn't feel like she was practicing on the top of her medical license. That was the language she used to mean that she had all this expertise in children and children's symptoms and diseases and disorders. And really the bulk of her job was about like kind of listening, hearing, and being attuned
比方说，育儿建议，或是讨论安全座椅，或是讨论当你无法入睡时的感受之类的话题。而母亲们极度需要这些。她能感受到另一端的需求，但她经常觉得自己像她对我说的那样，她不觉得自己是在发挥其行医执照最高水平的专业能力。那是她用来表达的意思，即她拥有关于儿童、儿童症状、疾病和失调的所有专业知识。而实际上，她工作的大部分内容都是关于倾听、聆听并对母亲们所说的话保持敏感。
to what the mothers were saying. And she ultimately ended up saying, you know, the mothers don't need me. They need, they need an hour with a good listener. I mean, all these stories in some ways reflect something that is an underlying theme here, Allison, which is that when we are not seen, when we're not heard, you know, we notice it. You know, we bring home a set of rocks and twigs and our mom throws them out. And you know, it feels like a big deal to us,
她最终说，你知道的，母亲们不需要我。她们需要的是，需要一个小时和一个好的倾听者。我的意思是，所有这些故事在某种程度上都反映了一个潜在的主题，艾莉森，那就是当我们没有被看见、没有被听见时，你知道的，我们会注意到。你知道的，我们带回家一套石头和树枝，而我们的妈妈把它们扔掉了。你知道的，这对我们来说是一件大事，
even though it doesn't feel like a big deal to the other person. On the other hand, someone spends 10 minutes listening to you and looking you in the eye, it makes a huge difference to us. Talk about just the emotional effect of feeling seen and feeling unseen. Yeah, I think that's the most important dimension of this for me is the emotional impact, because
尽管对另一个人来说这不算什么大事。另一方面，有人花10分钟听你倾听并看着你的眼睛，这对我们有着巨大的影响。谈谈被看见和未被看见所带来的纯粹情感影响吧。是的，我认为这是对我而言其中最重要的维度，即情感影响，因为
so many of the other impacts get kind of carried on along on the emotional impact. The emotional impact of being seen, people feel like they have dignity, people feel like they have understanding, people feel like they have purpose. Those are all things that other researchers, as well as my own research, has found. And when you're not seen, it can really dissuade you from following good advice, because you don't hear the good advice. You don't think that it's relevant to you, or it doesn't feel like it recognizes the particularities of your situation. None of us wants to be just another face in the crowd. All of us want to be seen for the unique individuals we are. And yet, the experience of being seen in this way can be dispiritingly rare.
许多其他的影响都会随着情感影响而产生或延续。被看见的情感影响是，人们会觉得自己有尊严，人们会觉得自己被理解，人们会觉得自己有目标。这些都是其他研究人员以及我自己的研究所发现的事情。而当你没有被看见时，这真的会劝阻你听从好的建议，因为你听不进去好的建议。你不会认为这与你有关，或者它感觉没有认可你具体处境的特殊性。我们谁都不想只是人群中的另一张面孔。我们所有人都希望作为独特的个体被看见。然而，以这种方式被看见的体验可能会令人沮丧地稀少。
When we come back, the psychological benefits of being seen and why it often doesn't happen. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Alison Pugh is a sociologist at Johns Hopkins University. In the course of conducting detailed interviews with people, she came to see she was performing a sort of therapy. She wasn't trying to be a therapist, but the people she talked with reported the experience of being deeply seen and heard felt therapeutic. Allison, as you notice the effects of people feeling seen, you
当我们回来时，我们将探讨被看见的心理益处以及为什么它往往不会发生。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。艾莉森·皮尤是约翰斯·霍普金斯大学的社会学家。在对人们进行详细访谈的过程中，她逐渐发现自己正在进行某种形式的治疗。她并不是想成为一名治疗师，但与她交谈的人报告说，那种被深深看见和听到的体验让人感到具有治疗作用。艾莉森，当你注意到人们被看见所带来的影响时，你
started to recognize the importance of this in different settings. You noticed this in your kids' schools, in doctors' offices, in community settings. In fact, you started to see this everywhere. That's right. It's kind of most obviously true for therapists. It's also true for teachers. It's also true for primary care physicians. So those seem like almost the most obvious cases,
开始认识到这在不同环境中的重要性。你在孩子们的学校、医生办公室、社区环境中都注意到了这一点。事实上，你开始到处都能看到这一点。没错。这对于治疗师来说显然是最明显的。对于老师来说也是如此。对于基层保健医生来说也是如此。所以这些似乎是最显而易见的例子，
but it's also true for, you know, I interviewed people who were like community organizers. I interviewed people who were funeral home directors, home healthcare aides, sex workers, even police. I interviewed a detective, I interviewed somebody who works with prison guards, you know, people you wouldn't expect to, you know, be particularly empathetic or who themselves might not talk about relationship as an important part of their work. But seeing the other is part
但这也是真的，你知道的，我采访过社区组织者这样的人。我采访过殡仪馆馆长、家庭医疗护理员、性工作者，甚至是警察。我采访过一名侦探，我采访过一个与狱警共事的人，你知道的，那些你不会指望他们会特别有同理心，或者他们自己可能不会把人际关系视为工作重要部分的人。但看见他人是人们在许多职业中履行职责的一部分。
of how people do their jobs across many occupations. When people sign up to be therapists, they know their job is to listen to other people, to try to really see them. But what Alison noticed was that people who went into lots of other fields were also discovering that an essential component of their jobs was paying close attention to the people around them. Being a great detective or dancer or computer programmer involves being skilled at human relationships. Allison started to call this work of seeing and hearing other people connective labor. Connective labor is the act of seeing the other and the other feeling seen.
当人们报名成为治疗师时，他们知道自己的工作就是倾听他人，努力真正看到他们。但艾莉森注意到的是，许多其他领域的人也发现，他们工作的一个必不可少组成部分是密切关注周围的人。成为一名出色的侦探、舞者或计算机程序员，都涉及精通人际关系。艾莉森开始把这种看见和倾听他人的工作称为“连接性劳动”。连接性劳动就是看见他人以及让他人感到自己被看见的行为。
You know, this is very common in sales, for example. If you want to sell something to somebody, they're more likely to buy it if you convey to them that you see that they have a particular problem that this solves or you see that they have a particular approach that this, you know, kind of works with or whatever. You know, like the seeing is kind of the engine powering so many different outcomes that we are pointing at and thinking about that is so important in so many different occupations. I mean, on the surface, you know, we might say we are sending a kid to a school because we want the kid to learn, you know, writing or algebra. We go to a doctor because we want
你知道的，这在销售中非常常见。如果你想把某样东西卖给某人，如果向他们传达你看到他们有一个特定的问题可以通过这个来解决，或者你看到他们有一个特定的方法可以与这个，你知道的，某种程度相契合，等等，他们就更有可能买单。你知道的，这种“看见”就像是驱动着许多不同结果的引擎，这些结果正是我们所指出的和思考的，在如此众多的不同职业中它是如此重要。我的意思是，从表面上看，你知道的，我们可能会说我们把孩子送去学校是因为我们想让孩子学习，你知道的，写作或代数。我们去看医生是因为我们想
to get a treatment for an illness. But what you're saying is that underlying those things actually happening, underlying someone learning algebra, underlying someone listening to their doctor, involves this system of trust and feeling seen. And if you don't experience that, you're much less likely to say, I want to play along. Exactly. What I felt was not known is how much these different occupations have in common and how it extends well beyond prototypical ones. So like the hairdresser also needs to be able to see you, to be able to give you a haircut that you want and have you accept that haircut and you know like it's actually a dynamic and that dynamic is common in many different kinds of jobs not just
为某种疾病寻求治疗。但你所说的是，在这些事情实际发生的基础之上，在一个人学习代数的基础之上，在一个人听取医生建议的基础之上，涉及的是这样一个信任和感觉被禁的系统。如果你没有体验到这一点，你就很可能会说：“我才不想奉陪。”完全正确。我当时感到不为人知的是，这些不同的职业有多少共同点，以及它如何远远超出了那些典型的职业。就像理发师也需要能够看见你，才能剪出你想要的发型并让你接受那个发型，你知道的，这其实是一个动态过程，而这种动态在许多不同类型的工作中都很常见，而不仅仅是
you know the ones that have articulated how important relationships are. Connective labor can often be invisible but when people don't have the skill to see and hear those around them, the lack of this invisible thing, it suddenly becomes very visible. Allison says connective labor is like engine grease. When you don't have it, the engine might still run, but you're going to hear some screeching sounds. So you can force yourself to learn even though you hate that teacher and they're not really seeing you and you're sitting in the back of the class and you can kind of roll that rock up the hill, but it's not going to be a pleasant or joyful experience and also you probably won't go as far as you could go. And that's true in many different fields.
你知道的那些已经阐明人际关系有多么重要的职业。连接性劳动往往是无形的，但当人们不具备看见和倾听周围人的技能时，这种无形事物的缺失，就会突然变得非常明显。艾莉森说，连接性劳动就像引擎润滑油。当你不具备它时，引擎可能仍然会运转，但你会听到一些刺耳的声音。所以你可以强迫自己去学习，即使你讨厌那个老师，而且他们并没有真正看你，你坐在教室的后排，你可以把那块巨石推上山，但这不会是一段愉快或快乐的体验，而且你可能也走不到你本来能走到的那么远。这在许多不同的领域都是如此。
I love the analogy to engine grease, because it truly is at some level it's invisible, but yet when it's not there, you can see the results very plainly. Mm-hmm, exactly, yeah. I think there's an assumption that the work of seeing and caring for people is largely women's work. You say that this assumption leads us to overlook the connective labor that many men perform, both in the workplace and in communities? Absolutely. This concept of connective labor, I'm really thinking of as it can be deployed
我喜欢引擎润滑油这个比喻，因为它在某种程度上确实是无形的，但当它不在时，你可以非常清楚地看到结果。嗯嗯，完全正确，是的。我认为存在这样一种假设：看见和照顾人的工作很大程度上是女性的工作。你说这个假设导致我们忽视了许多男性在工作场所和社区中表现出的连接性劳动？绝对是的。这个连接性劳动的概念，我真的认为它可以被部署
for all kinds of reasons. So it could be deployed for well-being, as the teachers or the therapists might do, but it could also be deployed for like persuasion, you could say. And that might be the sales people, or it could be deployed for control, and that might be as, you know, the hostage negotiator or the detective or, you know. So, many of those jobs, I'm sure you can hear, are occupied by men. So, I think, for instance, lawyers definitely need this, judges need this, and many of those are occupied by men. So, when you started talking about connective labor in public, did people resonate with that idea?
出于各种各样的原因。所以它可以为了福祉而被部署，就像老师或治疗师可能会做的那样，但它也可以为了说服而被部署，你可以这么说。那可能是销售人员，或者它可以为了控制而被部署，那可能是，你知道的，人质谈判专家或侦探，或者，你知道的。所以，其中的许多工作，我确信你能听到，都是由男性占据的。所以，我认为，例如，律师绝对需要这个，法官需要这个，其中许多都是由男性占据的。所以，当你开始公开谈论连接性劳动时，人们会对这个想法产生共鸣吗？
Did people recognize what that was, Allison? People would definitely come up to me afterward and say, you know, I'm a nurse and thank God that you're writing about this because I need to be able to go back to my employer and say, you know, I'm doing more than bedpans. I'm doing more than, you know, I'm doing more than bedpans, I'm doing more than, you know, medication timing. You know, this is important work of sitting and seeing the patient, you know, or the client. And they felt, I suppose they felt seen themselves, but it felt like it had important potential
人们能认出那是什么吗，艾莉森？人们事后绝对会走到我面前说，你知道的，我是一名护士，感谢上帝你在写这个，因为我需要能够回到我的雇主那里说，你知道的，我做的不仅仅是倒便盆。我做的不仅仅是，你知道的，我做的不仅仅是倒便盆，我做的不仅仅是，你知道的，安排服药时间。你知道的，这是坐下来看望病人或客户的重要工作。而且他们觉得，我想他们自己也觉得被看见了，但这感觉对他们在有关自己工作的对话中具有重要的潜在
impact for them in their conversations about their work. So when you started talking about connective labor in talks about your research with people, people would recognize that this was an important part of what it is that they were doing. But you say that they used the word magic to describe the power of connection that they themselves had seen firsthand, that when they connected with other people, magical things seemed to happen. Yeah, they definitely used the word magic to describe what they saw of the effects of seeing patients or students. You know, people definitely would come up and describe it as magical.
影响。所以，当你开始在关于你研究的演讲中向人们谈论连接性劳动时，人们会认识到这是他们所做事情的一个重要部分。但你说他们用“魔法”这个词来形容他们亲眼目睹的连接的力量，当他们与其他人建立连接时，似乎会发生神奇的事情。是的，他们绝对用“魔法”这个词来描述他们所看到的看见病人或学生的效果。你知道的，人们绝对会走过来把它描述为神奇的。
I think they use that word because we don't really understand it well. It's tied to this invisibility in that there's this really important process that's happening underneath all these, you know, economic tasks that we value and this kind of underlying process, shadowy, you know, opaque. We don't understand it well. And that's why people use the word magic, because it feels like it just comes upon us as this great gift without really understanding what goes into it and what produces it. I mean, I think we've all been in workplaces where, perhaps one boss
我认为他们使用这个词是因为我们并没有真正很好地理解它。它与这种无形性联系在一起，即在我们所重视的所有这些经济任务之下，正在发生着一个非常重要的过程，而这个潜在的过程是隐秘的、阴暗的、你知道的、不透明的。我们并没有很好地理解它。这就是为什么人们会使用“魔法”这个词，因为感觉它就像一份伟大的礼物一样降临在我们身上，却没有真正理解其中包含了什么以及是什么产生了它。我的意思是，我想我们都曾在这样的职场中待过，也许某个老板
is replaced by another boss and the new person basically, you know, really has a human touch to them. And within, you know, days or weeks sometimes, you know, a very toxic environment can be transformed and people are suddenly working together and they're cooperating together. And it does feel, you know, quite magical that something could have happened that quickly. Yeah. I mean, I've had that experience. And what I like about that example actually is that you're talking not just about the
被另一个老板取代了，新的人基本上，你知道的，确实带有一种人情味。而在有时几天或几周之内，你知道的，一个非常毒性的环境就可以被改变，人们突然开始共同工作并彼此合作。而且这确实感觉，你知道的，相当神奇，有些事情怎么会发生得这么快。是的。我的意思是，我有过那种体验。而我实际上喜欢那个例子的地方在于，你谈论的不仅是一个人看见你的
impact of one person seeing you, but also how we can create a kind of culture in which people are seeing others, that you're not the only person doing the seeing. So, really, a warm, competent leader can make an enormous difference, in part by catalyzing this kind of magic. You've tried to pinpoint the benefits of connection in different domains. One study by a group of researchers in Finland found that this type of connection helps us manage our emotions. Yes. I love that study. I think it's so well done. What they did was they had pairs of people who don't actually know each other tell stories to each other. And then they
影响，还有我们如何能够创造一种文化，在这种文化中人们能够看见其他人，你不是唯一一个在做“看见”这件事的人。所以，实际上，一个温暖、称职的领导者可以产生巨大的影响，部分原因就是通过催化这种魔法。你曾试图明确连接在不同领域的益处。芬兰一组研究人员的一项研究发现，这种类型的连接有助于我们管理情绪。是的。我喜欢那项研究。我认为它做得太棒了。他们做的是让互不相识的一对对人互相讲故事。然后他们
measured, I guess they had, you know, kind of wires attached to them while they did this. But they measured the emotional arousal of the storyteller and the story listener. And they found that when the listener conveyed that they heard and understood the other person, and you can imagine that's through nods or facial expressions or encouraging noises. The storytellers actually noticeably benefited. They felt calmer, their emotional arousal decreased, and the more their listeners conveyed this affiliation, the stronger the impact. Meanwhile, it also had an impact on the listeners. The more the listeners
测量，我想他们让这些人在这样做的时候连接了，你知道的，某种导线。但他们测量了讲故事的人和听故事的人的情绪唤醒度。他们发现，当倾听者传达出他们听到并理解了另一个人时——你可以想象那是通过点头、面部表情或鼓励的声音——讲故事的人实际上明显受益了。他们感到更平静，他们的情绪唤醒度下降了，而且听故事的人传达这种同盟感越多，影响就越强。与此同时，这也对听听故事的人产生了影响。听故事的人以这种方式结成同盟的程度越高
were allied in this way, you know, nods, facial expressions, encouraging noises, etc., the more they experienced increased arousal. So it was like the arousal moved from the storyteller to the listener as the storyteller was telling the story and as the listener was conveying that they understood and saw the other person. So it's a real sharing or spreading of the emotional load. It's a really beautifully designed study. In your own research you followed a
（你知道的，点头、面部表情、鼓励的声音等），他们的唤醒度增加得就越多。所以这就好像随着讲故事的人在讲故事，而听故事的人在传达他们理解并看到了另一个人时，情绪唤醒度从讲故事的人转移到了听故事的人身上。所以这是情感负担的真正共享或分担。这是一个设计得非常精美的研究。在你自己的研究中，你跟随了一位
chaplain you call her Erin as she went about her rounds at a hospital. And she recounted an incident where she helped a patient regulate some very intense emotions. Tell me the story she told you. Sure. Erin, she sees one patient who is intubated and he is so angry at being intubated. He didn't want to be intubated, even though the doctors told him he had to be because he would die otherwise. He couldn't speak, obviously, through the tube. He also couldn't write because he was on, I guess, medications that made that difficult. So he's just steaming full of fury. And then comes Erin, and she sees him.
你称之为埃琳的院牧，看她在医院里巡视。她讲述了一个事件，在这个事件中，她帮助一位患者调节了一些非常强烈的情绪。把她对你讲的故事讲给我听吧。当然。埃琳，她看到了一位插管的患者，他对插管感到非常愤怒。他不想插管，尽管医生告诉他必须插管，否则他会死的。显然，他通过那根管子无法说话。他也无法书写，因为我猜他服用的药物让那变得很困难。所以他简直满腔怒火。然后埃琳来了，她看见了他。
She sees this bottled up anger. And she says, you know, why don't you take this Kleenex box and like throw it, throw it against the wall. And he was so astounded, so relieved and powerfully moved by that, that he like grabs her arm and pulls her in and she sits with him for, you know, 15 minutes or 20 minutes. And then the next time she sees him, it's about, it's a couple days later and he's emerged from the procedure and he's no longer intubated. And he says to her, there is nothing like being in the worst moment of your life, and you feel like someone understands you.
她看到了这股压抑的怒火。她说，你知道的，你为什么不拿这个面巾纸盒，然后把它扔出去，朝墙上扔。他感到如此震惊、如此释怀并深受感动，以至于他一把抓住她的胳膊把她拉过来，她在那里陪了他，你知道的，15分钟或20分钟。然后下一次她见到他时，大约是几天后，他已经从手术中恢复过来，不再插管了。他对她说，没有什么比处于你生命中最糟糕的时刻、而你觉得有人理解你更好的了。
And that is such a perfect capture of what being seen feels like and what it can do for you in your worst moment. And of course the fact that she was sitting with him and holding his hand, it doesn't take away or change any of the physical things that he's going through, but some of what he's going through is not just physical, he's also experiencing emotional pain and presumably Erin was able to reduce some of that pain. Exactly. And there's actually a lot of research by psychologists and neuroscientists that show that, you know, when someone's holding your hand, it can alleviate pain. But here's an
这完美地捕捉到了被看见的感觉是什么样的，以及它能在你最糟糕的时刻为你做些什么。当然，她坐在他身边并握着他的手这一事实，并没有带走或改变他正在经历的任何身体上的事情，但他所经历的一部分不仅仅是身体上的，他还在经历情感上的痛苦，想必埃琳能够减轻一部分那种痛苦。完全正确。实际上有许多由心理学家和神经科学家进行的研究表明，你知道的，当有人握着你的手时，它可以减轻痛苦。但这却是一个
articulated moment where Hiram, the patient, is saying to Erin, you saw me and that was transporting. A feeling of connection might also help us learn new things. What have researchers discovered about the effects of being seen and heard for students, Helleson? So this is a really voluminous area. I have a couple of favorites. One author reviewed a thousand articles with 355,000 students and came away with this meta finding that among school-age children, he says, the effect size of teacher-student relationships is bigger than most typical educational innovations or curriculum changes.
明确的时刻，患者海勒姆对埃琳说：“你看到了我，那让人动容。”连接感也可能帮助我们学习新事物。艾莉森，研究人员对学生被看见和听到所产生的影响有什么发现？所以这是一个非常庞大的领域。我有几个最喜欢的。一位作者回顾了一千篇文章，涉及35.5万名学生，并得出这样一条元发现：在学龄儿童中，他说，师生关系的效果大小比大多数典型的教育创新或课程变革都要大。
So like the teacher-student relationship that underlies whether or not someone is learning algebra or can, you know, parse a sentence, that is more powerful, has a greater impact than, say, standard curriculum changes or other innovations. You might expect that to be true for the younger kids, maybe, but maybe less true for middle school or high schoolers. And actually, it's the opposite. The effect sizes are larger in studies that are conducted in higher grades. And teacher-student relationships are even more important when kids are academically at risk. You know, kids from disadvantaged economic backgrounds, for example, and kids with learning difficulties. So it's like even more important for adolescents even though we don't usually structure those schools to enable it to happen very well.
所以，就像是作为一个人是否在学习代数或能否分析句子的基础的师生关系，比方说，比标准的课程变革或其他创新更具力量、产生更大的影响。你可能会预计对于较小的孩子来说这是真的，也许对于中学生或高中生来说没那么真。而实际上，情况恰恰相反。在更高年级进行的研究所显示的效果大小更大。当孩子们在学术上处于危险之中时，师生关系甚至更重要。你知道的，例如来自弱势经济背景的孩子，以及有学习困难的孩子。所以它对青少年来说甚至更重要，尽管我们通常不会那样去构建这些学校来让这种事情能够很好地发生。
So this type of emotional connection also seems to be related to physical health. We touched on this a little bit earlier in our conversation, Allison. What is the effect on patients of feeling seen and heard by their doctors? There's a lot of research that talks about how being seen by one's doctor leads to better health outcomes and leads directly to patient well-being. And my favorite perhaps study here is a meta-analysis that has extremely strict inclusion criteria. So it's only randomized controlled trials in which the relationship between doctor and patient is experimentally manipulated. So, they tell the physicians to, you know, do or don't make eye contact or do or don't interrupt, et cetera. And
因此，这种情感连接似乎也与身体健康有关。我们在对话早些时候稍微触及过这一点，艾莉森。患者感受到被医生看见和听到，会产生什么影响？有很多研究讨论了被自己的医生看见如何带来更好的健康结果，并直接促进患者的福祉。我在这里或许最喜欢的研究是一项元分析，它具有极其严格的纳入标准。所以它只纳入随机对照试验，其中医生和患者之间的关系是通过实验进行操纵的。所以，他们告诉医生，你知道的，要或不要进行眼神接触，或者要或不要打断，等等。并且
based on that, these scholars, researchers conclude that the impact of clinician-patient relationship on health outcomes was significant and exceeded that of taking an aspirin every day to ward off heart attacks. Wow. So, I mean, it has sort of actual physical consequences here, not just psychological consequences. Exactly.
基于此，这些学者、研究人员得出结论，临床医生与患者关系对健康结果的影响是显著的，并且超过了每天服用阿司匹林来预防心脏病发作的效果。哇。所以，我的意思是，这在某种程度上具有实际的身体后果，而不仅仅是心理后果。完全正确。
I mean, think how many people take an aspirin every day to ward off heart attacks, and this is something that actually exceeds even that. You know, an experience of being seen by a chaplain or a teacher or a doctor can be quite intense. But research has also found that, you know, being seen by a passing acquaintance can also make a difference to our well-being. We've featured Gillian Sandstrom and Liz Dunn on Hidden Brain before. Tell me about some of their work, looking at the effects of even casual acquaintances noticing us as we go through our day.
我的意思是，想想有多少人每天服用阿司匹林来预防心脏病发作，而这竟然是甚至超过那项效果的事情。你知道的，被院牧、老师或医生看见的体验可能会非常强烈。但研究还发现，你知道的，被路过的熟人看见也可以对我们的福祉产生影响。我们以前在《隐藏的大脑》中介绍过吉莉安·桑德斯特姆和莉兹·邓恩。给我们讲讲他们的一些研究，看看即使是我们在日常生活中遇到的泛泛之交注意到我们，也会产生什么影响。
Yeah, they've done great work on this stuff. The first, the study that I most enjoy thinking and talking about is they experimentally varied how cafe customers interacted with baristas and then they measured their well-being afterward. And they gave some participants, they gave them instructions to like, you know, have a genuine interaction with the cashier, smile, make eye contact, and have a brief conversation. That was the social condition. And then they had the efficient condition. Those participants were told, make your interaction with the cashier as efficient as possible, have your money ready, and avoid unnecessary conversation. And it found that people who took the time to have a social interaction with the barista,
是的，他们在这些方面做出了出色的研究。首先，我最喜欢思考和谈论的研究是，他们通过实验改变了咖啡馆顾客与咖啡师互动的方式，然后测量了他们之后的福祉。他们给一些参与者指示，你知道的，与收银员进行真诚的互动，微笑道别、进行眼神接触并进行简短的对话。那是社交条件。然后他们设置了高效条件。那些参与者被告知，让您与收银员的互动尽可能高效，准备好零钱，并避免不必要的对话。结果发现，花时间与咖啡师进行社交互动的人，
that increased people's sense of belonging. You know, the study and its two conditions point to one reason many of us don't stop to see one another and that's because many of us, in fact, are frenetically busy and harried as we move through the day. And it's hard to notice the person in front of you when you feel like you have to be in two places at the same time. Yes, that is a quite profound observation actually, because what makes us busy? There's a couple of things that lead to it,
这增强了人们的归属感。这项研究及其两种条件指出了我们许多人不愿停下来去看见彼此的一个原因，那就是我们中的许多人，事实上，在度过每一天时都忙碌狂热且行色匆匆。当你觉得必须同时身处两个地方时，很难注意到眼前的这个人。是的，这实际上是一个相当深刻的观察，因为是什么让我们变得忙碌？导致这种情况的有几件事，
but in the United States, a lot of times what makes you busy is an inordinate work schedule, kind of overworking, can really shrink the amount of time we have for the other parts of our lives. And if, oops if research like this suggests that if you don't kind of give the time and space to those unscripted, trivial encounters throughout your life, if you're always trying to make everything so efficient so that you can maximize the time that you have available for other pursuits, that can have well-being effects.
但在美国，很多时候让你忙碌的是过分的工作日程，某种过度工作，真的会缩减我们用于生活其他部分的时间。如果——噢，如果这样的研究表明，如果你不把时间和空间给予你生活中那些未经脚本编排的、琐碎的相遇，如果你总是试图让一切都变得如此高效，以便最大限度地利用可用于其他追求的时间，这可能会对福祉产生影响。
I mean, it is the case that sometimes when we see people who are masters of communication, people are just really good and fun to be around. They often have an unhurried air about them. And sometimes these are very busy people, but they somehow are able to communicate a sense that they're not in a rush. Yeah, I mean, I've seen that too. I'm always amazed. One of my brothers, for example,
我的意思是，事实确实如此，有时当我们看到那些精通沟通的大师时，那些真的很优秀、与他们相处很有趣的人，他们通常有一种从容不迫的气质。有时这些人非常忙碌，但他们不知何故能够传达出一种他们并不急躁的感觉。是的，我的意思是，我也见过那样的情况。我总是感到惊叹。例如，我的兄弟之一，
is always really good at honoring the moment, kind of. Just being there present with the other person. But he's also often late. And I, on the other hand, am really almost never late. And I really need to teach myself. I have needed to teach myself to pause and, you know, who's this person that I'm kind of blowing by. Yeah. I've had relatives like this as well who are often perennially late, but they're often people who are more than happy to have a conversation. And when they ask someone, how are you, and the person actually gives you a five-minute answer, they actually sit and listen, and they will ask follow-up questions.
总是非常擅长尊重当下，某种程度上。只是与另一个人同在并陪伴在那里。但他也经常迟到。而另一方面，我几乎从来不迟到。我真的需要教导自己。我一直需要教导自己停下来，然后，你知道的，我正从谁身边这样呼啸而过。是的。我也有过这样的亲戚，他们总是老是迟到，但他们往往是那些非常乐意交谈的人。当他们问别人“你好吗”，而那个人真的回答了整整五分钟时，他们真的会坐下来倾听，并且会问后续的问题。
And then it's not surprising that they don't show up on time to wherever they're going. Yeah, I mean like maybe we should, we who are not late, should be more understanding that those who are are helping you know. Seeing others for who they truly are has many benefits for their emotions, for their health, for their learning. It also has benefits for us, and yet many of us feel it occurs too infrequently in our harried world. When we come back, how to actually see another person and the surprising transformations this can produce in them and in us. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
然后，他们没有按时到达他们要去的地方也就不足为奇了。是的，我的意思是，也许我们应该——我们这些不迟到的人应该多一些理解，理解那些迟到的人正在帮助你知道的。以本来的面目看见他人，对他们的情绪、健康和学习都有很多益处。它对我们自己也有益处，然而我们许多人觉得在我们这个匆忙的世界里，这种事情发生得太少。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何真正地看见另一个人，以及这能在他们身上和我们身上产生怎样的惊人转变。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Allison Pugh is a sociologist at Johns Hopkins University. She's the author of The Last Human Job, the work of connecting in a disconnected world. Allison says it's possible for people to learn to get better at seeing other people. In fact, she teaches this skill to students. Yes, I realized that the in-depth interviewing that I do that involves this kind of seeing is a clinical practice. And it's a clinical practice like nursing and like teaching and like therapy. And what do all of those professions have in common is they have an apprentice model of teaching
Allison Pugh 是约翰斯·霍普金斯大学的社会学家。她是《最后的人类工作：在脱节的世界中建立连接》一书的作者。Allison 表示，人们可以通过学习来提高洞察他人的能力。事实上，她就把这项技能教给学生。是的，我意识到我所做的深入采访涉及这种洞察，这是一种临床实践。这就像护理、教学和治疗一样是一种临床实践。所有这些职业的共同点在于，它们都采用学徒制的教学模式，
in which someone does something in front of other people and then gets immediate feedback. One of the first things that they have to do is kind of get out of the way. And I often like to think about airspace as like a soccer ball and who is controlling the soccer ball. And you want to pass the soccer ball, you know. If you're too present, then the other person just doesn't have the space to put themselves in there. And that can preclude, that can impede seeing of the other for sure.
即一个人在其他人面前做某事，然后立即得到反馈。他们要做的第一件事之一就是有点退居二线。我经常喜欢把谈话空间（airspace）想象成一个足球，看谁在控制这个足球。你知道的，你想把足球传出去。如果你在场上表现得太强眼，那么对方就没有空间把自己融入其中。这肯定会妨碍、阻碍对对方的观察。
It's also the case that sometimes as people talk, you know, we have very quick interpretations of what it is that they're saying and sometimes we have very quick reactions to what they're saying. Talk a moment about the importance of trying to set those things aside as well, setting aside, you know, our assumptions and expectations in order to be truly good listeners and how difficult that can be to do. Yeah, so if you're like completely sure that the other person is really passionate about such and such and you say that to them and they're like, no, actually it's more like this, this is what I actually care about. You have to hear that. And actually, the correcting process can help people feel even more seen.
同样的情况是，有时当人们说话时，你知道，我们对他们所说的话会有非常迅速的解读，有时我们对他们所说的话会有非常快速的反应。请花一点时间谈谈努力将这些东西放在一边的重要性，也就是抛开我们的假设和期望，以便成为真正优秀的倾听者，以及做到这一点有多难。是的，如果你完全确信对方对某事非常热情，你对他们这么说，而他们却说，不，其实更像是这样，这才是真正让我关心的事情。你必须倾听这一点。事实上，纠正的过程可以帮助人们感觉被看得更清楚。
If they are able to correct you and you say, oh, yes, now I get it. The other thing I would say is in our quickness to leap into a conversation with somebody with our own views or assumptions, what I think is really important is actually hearing what the other person is not saying, hearing the emotion that they're not naming. If you can hear an emotion behind what someone's saying and say, wow, it sounds like you're feeling nervous about that,
如果他们能够纠正你，而你说，哦，是的，我现在明白了。我要说的另一件事是，在我们急于带着我们自己的观点或假设跳入与某人的对话中时，我认为真正重要的是倾听对方没有说出口的话，倾听他们没有说出口的情绪。如果你能听到某人所说的话背后的情绪并说，哇，听起来你对此感到紧张，
or it sounds like you're feeling, it sounds like that gives you a lot of pride. It doesn't have to be a negative emotion. It's like if you can kind of hear whatever emotion is behind, that's very powerful for people. If they didn't say it and you name it, they feel very seen. And kind of in the naming,
或者听起来你感到，听起来这给了你很大的自豪感。它不一定是一个负面情绪。如果你能听到背后隐藏着什么情绪，这对人们来说是非常有力量的。如果他们没有说出来而你指出来了，他们会觉得自己被深深地看见了。而在这种指出过程中，
when you're doing that kind of naming, you're making it safe for them. In some ways, being able to get one level below what they're saying, to sort of say, I can recognize that you're feeling pride or I can recognize that you're feeling sad, that might be even more effective than just simply repeating back to people, here's what I'm hearing you say, or repeating back their words to them, because it really shows that you have actually taken in what they have said, you understood it,
当你进行这种指认时，你是在为他们营造安全感。在某种程度上，能够探究到他们所说内容下一层的东西，比如说，我能看出你感到自豪，或者我能看出你感到难过，这可能比单纯向人们重复“这就是我听到你说的”或向他们重复他们的话更有效，因为它真正表明你确实吸收了他们所说的话，你理解了，
and you're actually trying to give the essence of it back to them. Exactly, that's why it's like, it's a boost, a huge boost. Now I would also say it's a little more challenging, maybe. But it is true that if you can bump it up a level and go to what's not being said out loud, but that you really perceive, that if we happen to not see someone accurately, if we mis-see someone, this can itself be an opportunity.
而且你实际上是在试图把它的精髓反馈给他们。没错，这就是为什么它像是一个动力，一个巨大的动力。现在我也要说，这可能更有挑战性。但事实是，如果你能把它提升一个层次，触及那些没有大声说出来但你确实感知到的东西，如果我们碰巧没有准确地看到某人，如果我们看错了某人，这本身也可以是一个机会。
If we stop to show the other person that we really do want to see them and to correct ourselves, you interviewed a therapist whom you call Sarah who told you that an episode of mis-seeing was actually crucial to her patient's progress. Can you tell me that story? LESLIE KENDRICK Yeah. So, Sarah was a therapist at the VA hospital, and so she was seeing veterans, and she said she had, she told me about a woman she had been seeing who had experienced sexual trauma in the military. And at the end of like the third or fourth week, the woman leaves the session with a comment saying that she might not be able to come back. You know, how she might get busy is what she said to Sarah. And Sarah said to me, you know, something was just kind
如果我们停下来向对方表明我们确实想看清他们并纠正自己，你采访了一位你称之为 Sarah 的治疗师，她告诉你的一次看走眼其实对她病人的进展至关重要。你能给我讲讲那个故事吗？LESLIE KENDRICK：好的。所以，Sarah 是退伍军人医院的一名治疗师，所以她接待的是退伍军人，她说她有一个病人，她跟我谈起过一个她一直在接待的女性，这位女性在军队中经历过性创伤。在大约第三周或第四周结束时，这位女性在离开治疗时留下了一句话，说她可能无法再回来了。你知道的，她可能会变得很忙，这就是她对 Sarah 说的话。Sarah 对我说，你知道，有些事情就是不太对劲，
of off. Like it didn't feel the same. It just didn't feel right. So she calls her before the next week. And she says to her, you know, I think I said something. You know, I'm wondering if I maybe missed something or didn't hear something right. The session felt different today. And I think it could be helpful to talk about that if
就像感觉不对一样。就是感觉不对劲。所以在下周之前她给她打电话。她对她说，你知道，我想我说了些什么。你知道，我在想我可能漏掉了什么或者没有听对。今天的会谈感觉不一样了。我想如果
you're able to come in again." So the woman comes in, she comes back, and they were able to talk. And Sarah said, at that point, the relationship really shifted, and she ended up making tons of progress. And so at the end of the treatment, Sarah asks the woman, you know, what worked for you? And the woman said, there was this point where you noticed that I wasn't happy with whatever you did. And the fact that you even noticed that was a big deal. And so, Sarah took away from that this notion of actually therapists have written about this.
你能再来一趟，谈谈这个可能会有帮助。”于是这位女性来了，她回来了，他们能够进行交谈。Sarah 说，在那之后，关系真的发生了转变，她最终取得了巨大的进展。所以在治疗结束时，Sarah 问这位女性，你知道，什么对你有用？这位女性说，有那么一刻，你注意到我对你所做的任何事情都不满意。你甚至能注意到这一点，这太了不起了。所以，Sarah 从中领悟到一个概念，其实治疗师们对此写过文章，
They call it therapeutic rupture and that if you can redeem yourself there, if you manage a reconciliation, it can be powerfully transformative to the people who are being seen and heard, but you also are finding that the act of seeing and hearing others can be powerfully transformative for us. You tell the story of a nurse practitioner whom you call Birdie. Can you tell me her story, Allison? So, Birdie was a nurse practitioner in California.
他们称之为“治疗断裂”（therapeutic rupture），如果你能在那里挽回自己，如果你能设法达成和解，它对被看到和被听到的人来说可以产生强大的变革作用，但你也会发现，看到和听到他人的行为对我们自己来说也可以产生强大的变革作用。你讲了一位你称之为 Birdie 的执业护士的故事。Allison，你能给我讲讲她的故事吗？Birdie 是加利福尼亚州的一名执业护士。
She had this bright smile, you know, a high beam smile. And she was quite kind of bustling and friendly and very warm. And she told me that she had always assumed she would be a doctor like her father until she failed organic chemistry. And she then kind of was like, what am I going to do next? So she actually decides to become a nurse practitioner, but even as a nurse practitioner, she said, she struggled with ego issues. This is what she said. But the good thing about being a nurse, she said, is that she could focus on the human element. And she told me an example of what she considered really to epitomize what nursing meant to her. And that was the example of this homeless man.
她有着灿烂的笑容，你知道的，那种光芒四射的笑容。她非常忙碌、友好而且非常热情。她告诉我，她一直以为自己会像父亲一样成为一名医生，直到她在有机化学考试中不及格。然后她有点茫然：我接下来要做什么？所以她实际上决定成为一名执业护士，但即使作为一名执业护士，她说，她也一直在与自我意识作斗争。这是她说的。但当护士的好处是，她说，她可以专注于人的要素。她给我讲了一个她认为真正体现了护理对她意味着什么的例子。那个例子是一个无家可归的男人。
He came into her clinic. He had been on the streets for years. She said he had probably walked cross-country homeless back and forth. He had never really been in a shelter. She said he had some wounds on his feet. They were, she said, just gnarly, calloused. And she said he was so hunched over from years of osteoporosis and walking,
他走进了她的诊所。他在街头流浪多年。她说他可能背着行囊全国各地无家可归地走来走去。他从来没有真正住过收容所。她说他的脚上有一些伤口。她说那些伤口简直盘根错节、布满老茧。她说他因为多年的骨质疏松症和走路而驼背得厉害，
and so few people would be able to even have eye contact with him because he physiologically couldn't even really look up. And I just sat and did wound care for his feet. So she just sat and washed and cleaned his wounds. And she said, it wasn't going to do much. He was still going to be on his feet all the time. He was so resistant to going into any shelter.
以至于很少有人能够甚至与他对视，因为他从生理上来说真的无法抬头。我只是坐在那里为他的脚做伤口护理。所以她只是坐下来为他清洗伤口。她说，这起不到太大作用。他仍然会一直到处走动。他非常抵触去任何收容所。
It was just a band-aid over a really big problem. But for her, it captured what nursing was about, like this humility, this service, and the witnessing. So she said, she tells me, just to give him that moment of, I'm seeing you, I'm acknowledging you, this is me caring for you. She said it was powerful for both of us. You know, I'm reminded of this new story I just saw about Pope Francis in 2024. He washed and kissed the feet of 12 women who were incarcerated at a prison in Rome. You know, the Pope was
这只是一块贴在巨大问题上的创可贴。但对她来说，这捕捉到了护理的真谛，比如这种谦逊、这种服务和见证。所以她说，她告诉我，只是为了给他那样一个时刻：我正在看着你，我在承认你的存在，这是我在照顾你。她说这对我们俩来说都很有力量。你知道的，这让我想起了我刚刚看到的关于 2024 年教宗方济各的一则新闻。他为罗马一座监狱里的 12 名女性囚犯洗脚并亲吻了她们的脚。你知道的，教宗当时
in a wheelchair, so the women were sitting on a raised stage and he was wheeled from one person to the next. What was remarkable to me when I watched the video of this event was to see the reaction of the women. I mean, uniformly they were weeping and it was clear that no one had put them on a pedestal in a long time, no one had seen them. And so the effects of seeing someone really has transformative effects on both the seer and the person being seen. Exactly. The power of just connecting to another human being. And by doing that connecting, you're saying to the other person, you are a person of value. You have humanity humanity just like I do,
坐在轮椅上，所以这些女性坐在高高的舞台上，他被推着从一个人到另一个人。当我观看这一事件的视频时，最令我惊奇的是看到这些女性的反应。我的意思是，她们异口同声地在哭泣，很显然，已经很久没有人把她们放在神坛上了，很久没有人真正看到过她们了。因此，看到某人的效果确实对旁观者和被看到的人都具有变革性的影响。完全正确。仅仅与另一个人建立连接的力量。通过这种连接，你是在对另一个人说：你是一个有价值的人。你拥有像我一样的人性，
and together we are sharing this moment. It confers dignity and humanity to both participants. In our companion episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we look at how powerful forces are getting in the way of our seeing one another as people. These forces are everywhere, and they're systematically making it harder for teachers, doctors, parents, and caregivers to really see and hear the people they are working with. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled, Recovering the Human Touch. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org.
我们共同分享着这个时刻。它赋予了双方尊严和人性。在我们的伴随节目中（仅向 Hidden Brain Plus 订户开放），我们探讨了强大的力量是如何阻碍我们把彼此当作人来看待的。这些力量无处不在，它们系统性地让老师、医生、父母和照顾者更加难以真正看到和听到与他们合作的人。如果您是订阅者，该节目现在就可以收听。它的标题是《找回人性的触感》。如果您还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。
If you're using an Apple device, you can go to apple.co.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, you can go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. You'll get a free seven-day trial in both places and you'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Allison Pugh is a sociologist at Johns Hopkins University. She's the author of The Last Human Job, the work of connecting in a disconnected world. Allison, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you.
如果您使用的是苹果设备，您可以访问 apple.co.hiddenbrain.org。如果您使用的是苹果设备，您可以访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。您将在两个地方获得为期七天的免费试用，并将立即访问我们所有仅限订阅者的内容。再次强调，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain。Allison Pugh 是约翰斯·霍普金斯大学的社会学家。她是《最后的人类工作：在脱节的世界中建立连接》一书的作者。Allison，非常感谢你今天来到 Hidden Brain。谢谢你。
If you have a follow-up question for Allison, and you'd be willing to share it with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone. Once you've done so, email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line connection. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Burns, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury.
如果您对 Allison 有后续问题，并且愿意与 Hidden Brain 的听众分享，请在您的手机上录制一段语音备忘录。录制完成后，请将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。该电子邮件地址再次是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题词 connection。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括 Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quirell、Ryan Katz、Autumn Burns、Andrew Chadwick 和 Nick Woodbury。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. Thanks for listening. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Tara Boyle 是我们的执行制片人。我是 Hidden Brain 的执行编辑。感谢收听。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。